all right let's have a look at this next
one cuz it sneaky I'm now gonna
astronaut a probability and it's just
it's just a number okay but um I'm
asking for a negative one cuz we can
have negative Z scores as well can't we
okay
negative Z scores represent things that
are underneath the mean yes now the
problem with this table is there are no
negative Zed scores on here there's no
negative 0.72 but it doesn't matter
because the normal distribution remember
is symmetrical right so values as we
read them to the right should be the
same as values as we read them to the
left right so what I would say is before
I go to read the table I'm gonna say to
actually work this out it's equivalent
to the probability of like bethey on the
left hand side is the same as the
probability that's equivalent on the
right hand side do you agree with that
from yeah it's just it's just the other
way
right ah would I check a - at the front
here have a think what are we
calculating again this is a this is an
area under curve and it's a probability
density function probability density
functions are always positive so no
negatives at the front that make sense
right yeah okay
now by the way you can't just change
something because you're like I would
like this it's more convenient to me cuz
on my table you need to provide a reason
for that so I would say by symmetry
because the normal distribution has this
as one of its chief qualities that it's
a symmetrical function okay so once I've
established that I can now go to the
table and read the appropriate value so
I'm looking for 0.72 can you see where
that is
yeah good so here's the point here's the
point seven row and then here's the
point zero two column so you can see the
0.26 for two at the intersection point
so far so good
alright so let me write that down
0.26 for two now this next example here
I want you to think about carefully
write those first two a and B they both
at zero as an endpoint or start point
which is nice because that's the table
is measuring from zero but this one
doesn't so how can we solve this problem
how can we still use the table to come
up with a probability like this we're
trying to still use the table knowing
what are you thinking you're talking
about are you talking out here
ah okay so do you know this are you
talking about this why this is a good
question there's the same question a
storehouse why is this positive and not
negative because I can't have a negative
probability remember the question is
what is the probability of getting a
z-score but probability is always
positive does that make sense
so probability of a negative z-score is
still a positive number because it's a
probability okay
all right now come to this guy here it
might be helpful to represent this on a
diagram okay so what I'd like you to do
is where you're doing the working for
this question I'm just drawing yourself
a little horizontal line here this is
gonna be a z axis okay doing in blue so
here's a dead asks us now if I'm looking
for the probability from 0.5 to one
point two three right which is actually
a number that we saw before I need to
know where 0.5 is and then Internet
where one point two three is sorry that
scale is not amazing but you get the
idea
this interval in here Z these are the
z-scores that I'm actually interested in
between 0.5 and 1 point 2 3 okay now do
you agree that I can work that I can
work out that probability by saying it
is the difference between this
probability here right that's from
naught to 1 point 2 3 we already know
what the answer is for that it's the
difference between that and the part
that's before that so I'm gonna or am I
going to be able to delete that there we
go
how's that for fair to your work ok
there we go do you see the actual
probability I want which is this guy
right it's the difference between this
longer probability and you take away
this little section here
does that make sense and the reason why
I stated in these two ways below is
because I can get both of those values
from my table that make sense one point
two three we did that one before didn't
we what was it 0.3 907 that's the
probability for that section can you go
to the table and get the one for 0.5
yeah there you go right there you can
see it I hope
whoopsie-daisy I don't need any thing
after the noir point 5 so it's not 0.5 0
essentially so there's my number zero
point one nine one five so the way I'm
gonna state this on my working is it's
the probability of from zero to one
point two three and I am subtracting the
probability from 0 to 0.5 okay I think
it's super important when you're reading
things off a table that you say where
you got them on the table because so
easy just to write down numbers and then
when you come back to work this out
maybe you'll like try and understand I
do this wrong so do it right you're
checking you're like I don't know where
these numbers come from I can't remember
that was like half an hour ago okay so
actually providing this explanation of
where I'm reading off the table is
really important so it's zero point
three nine oh seven takeaway this can
someone already reach for their
calculator and got an answer one point
zero point nine nine two are you happy
with that
yeah and of course you can go back to
your normal distribution it's up the top
I'm trying not to go too far so you can
see what's going on because up there and
it's it's a section in the middle right
so it's a thinner one and you can say
yeah point one nine nine two does make
sense okay let me pause there before I
have a look at our next example it's a
bit trickier any questions
happy alright I will scroll back if you
would need it but I want you to have a
look at this guy here you're gonna need
to have a think about this for a second
and I'm going to let you have a couple
minutes to catch up with your notes and
also try and absorb what this question
is asking you okay
it says given normally distributed data
I'm giving you a mean I'm giving you
variance see if you can work out this
probability have a think I wonder how
you went let's have a go together it
says given normally distributed data so
therefore I know I can use everything
that I know about the normal
distribution and then they start telling
you specific information and when I say
they I mean me I start telling you
specific information about this normal
distribution so right at the top here
you've got a mean of 120 what letter do
we usually used to signify that that's
me mu equals 120 right and then the next
thing they tell you and we haven't heard
this word for a few days right the next
thing I tell you is variance okay now we
would say like var X equals right but
another notation which I think is more
helpful in this context does anyone
remember the other way to say variance
Sigma squared right so I'm gonna write
Sigma squared equals 225 the reason why
this is helpful is because to do all
this stuff with z-scores you need the
standard deviation which is just regular
old Sigma naught Sigma squared okay so
from this even before I read anything
else I can immediately say I know what
the standard deviation is it's the
square root of the variance so therefore
therefore it's 15 okay good we can
crunch numbers good so I've got me I've
got my Sigma and then it says find the
probability of randomly selecting a
score less than 129 okay so I'm just
going to move this over so I can write
it all on one side so I want to this is
the question now what's the probability
of getting a score less than a hundred
and twenty nine this is the question
okay now I can work this out but I need
to do a bit of translating first because
the table of values that we're going to
use doesn't have raw scores in it it has
z-scores or standardized scores is what
we also call them right so this X being
129 I've got to convert that into Z
beaten whatever it happens to be okay so
let's go ahead and do that I'll do my
working in a different color this as you
can see is just all the stuff from the
okay so if x equals 129 what's the
z-score I'm going to get from that can
you help me remember my formula for Zed
school it's gonna be I think it's gonna
be score - mean X minus mu right all
divided by standard deviation Sigma so
that in this case is 15 yeah that's a 9
on the top 9 over 15 1915 is 3/5 so this
is 0.6 are you okay with that so this is
the number for the z-score but as you
saw up above in our previous examples
right you can't just like go to the
table and just say all great I've got a
value and I just read that as my heart
saw sometimes you've got to do weird
things like like subtracting or adding
or whatever happens to be so I've got to
know how to interpret the numbers on the
table so to do that I'm gonna pull out
this same trick that I was doing before
and if you didn't do this I highly
encourage you I am going to draw myself
a little z axis here so this is going to
be my scores for Zed and what I'm
looking for is the probability of having
as is called less than 0.6 less than 0.6
so where is that okay so if I put my 0
right in the middle if I go like 1 2 3
etc I guess 0.6 would be about there is
that okay and what I want is all of the
scores are less than that is that okay
this is the section I'm an interested in
right now I wonder if you can tell
what's the most helpful way to slice and
dice this section this interval on the z
axis in order to be able to use the
table right
um if for example I went to the table
and maybe very done this and I went and
found the value for 0.6 what is that
value by the way
yep fantastic so you can see it right
there there it is 0.2 to 5/7 okay what
does that even correspond to well you
start from zero and then you got to 0.6
you're gray so on my um my little number
line here that's this whoopsie-daisy
keep doing this that's this section in
here right the area under that section
of the curve will be zero point two two
five seven approximately but that
doesn't include all the parts that I
want there's all the other stuff to the
left how do I work out that probability
all that stuff to the left yeah this
right I'm looking at one whole half of
the normal distribution the entire
normal distribution is one so therefore
the left-hand side of it will be zero
point five do you agree so I've got this
section over here in fact it doesn't
even end it's just this section it just
keeps on going forever right if it's a
probability density function that whole
thing better app add up to a half okay
so now that I've interpreted that I can
then say well here's my probability
right the probability of getting a
z-score less than 0.6 will be equal to
and again rather than just going
straight to the numbers I want to write
down what probabilities correspond to
those numbers so let's do this from left
to right it's the probability of having
a negative dead score so that's Z is
less than zero that's the one on the
left and then I have to add that to the
one from zero up to point six you see
what I did there there's the two
sections okay so now I can pop my
numbers in point five point two two five
seven and we don't need a calculator for
that does that make sense yeah and again
always please do this right do a quick
sense check for yourself zero point two
seven two five seven is that a
reasonable number go back to your normal
distribution go back to your picture
here it is what do we say point six
right so I'm a balling that's gonna be
somewhere around here
there you go right I want everything
less than that so what I'm going to be
shading is
be over here right what was the answer
we got again 0.25 7 does that orange
shading look like 72% I'm pretty happy
with that it's certainly close enough
that I haven't gotten something that's
out of the ballpark okay